après le handball un tout autre sport
moins connu le eSport souvenez-vous
jusqu'à il y a quelques années le
dreamac enfin la dreamac était le
rendez-vous des fans de jeux vidéo à
Tours le collectif de streamer tour en
jeu Solary a voulu relancer l’engouement
ce week-end en organisant le slilane au
Palais des Congrès de Tours une
compétition rassemblant plus de 800
gamers sur 4 jeux vidéo différents parmi
eux seulement une soixantaine de femmes
et là le chapelet est allé à leur
rencontre
ils ont passé le week-end les yeux rivés
sur leur écran de PC pour la première
édition de la slilane 800 joueurs se
sont retrouvés au Palais des Congrès de
Tours pour participer à l'un des quatre
tournois de jeux vidéo proposés
plusieurs salles et plusieurs ambiances
avec tout de même une constante une
grande majorité de jeune homme quelques
filles font pourtant de la résistance
comme Aude ici avec son casque blanc
elle est venue de Lille pour jouer à
League of Legends son pseudo c'est Louis
qui est dans son équipe quatre garçons
on n'a pas forcément l'esprit compétitif
autant que les garçons du coup pour les
cheveux compter les compétitifs c'est un
peu compliqué de s'intégrer après on n'a
pas forcément les mêmes chances au
niveau des équipes etc on n'a pas
forcément le bon accompagnement
on peut mettre sous-estimé parfois et
pour encadrer l'équipe Sandrine elle est
la maman du seul tour en jeu de la bande
pendant 15 ans à la coaching une équipe
de hand et elle retrouve dans cette
compétition de nombreux points communs
avec ce qu'il lui plaît tant dans le
sport
[Musique]
une stratégie d'équipe une attaque une
défense et puis après ben on s'adapte à
chaque fois à la situation la nouveauté
ce qui se passe en face voilà et moi je
trouve ça formidable parce que ils sont
capables de faire et encore une fois
c'est pas juste être derrière son
ordinateur ça implique beaucoup de
choses et je pense que tout le monde a
pas assez de conscience de ce que ça
implique
l'événement était organisé par Solary
l'équipe de eSport tour en gel à la clé
pour les meilleurs 25000 euros de gains
à se partager une première édition qui
devrait revenir désormais chaque année